- [Instructor] Before
we get into the topic
of weak acid equilibria, let's
look at a strong acid first.
So let's say that HA is a strong
acid and reacts with water
to produce the hydronium ion and A-minus,
the conjugate base to HA.
Technically, the reaction
comes to an equilibrium.
However, the equilibrium
favors the products so much
that we don't draw an equilibrium arrow.
We simply draw an arrow going to the right
indicating at equilibrium,
we have essentially
all H30-plus and A-minus, and no HA.
So we assume that a strong
acid ionizes 100% in solution,
and we can see that in
our particulate diagrams.
And keep in mind that
these particulate diagrams
are not meant to represent
the entire solution,
just a small portion of
it so we can get an idea
about what's happening
in the entire solution.
We can think about the
particulate diagram on the left
representing the initial
concentration of our acid, HA.
So there are five HA particles in solution
and also five water particles.
Since the reaction goes to completion,
the HA particles are going to
react with the water particles
to produce five hydronium,
H3O-plus, and five A-minus.
We can see that in our
second particulate diagram,
which represents the equilibrium mixture
and there are five hydroniums present
and also five A-minuses.
We can write the equilibrium
constant expression
for this reaction from
the balanced equation.
we look at our products and
say it'd be the concentration
of H3O-plus, and since
there's a coefficient of one,
it'd be the concentration of H30-plus
raised to the first power,
times the concentration
of A-minus also raised to
the first power, divided by
the concentration of HA
raised to the first power,
and pure water is left out
of the equilibrium constant expression.
So that's equal to the
equilibrium constant K,
and since this shows the
ionization of an acid,
we could call this Ka value,
the acid ionization constant,
or the acid dissociation constant.
Since the equilibrium
lies so far to the right
for a strong acid, at
equilibrium, there's going to be
essentially all products and
very, very little reactants.
That means the Ka value for a strong acid
will be much greater than one.
Now let's look at a weak acid.
We're gonna use the same
general equation here.
HA plus H2O yields H3O-plus plus A-minus.
However, if HA is a generic weak acid,
we're going to include an
equilibrium arrow here.
The equilibrium arrow needs to be included
because weak acids only partially ionize,
and we can see that in
the particulate diagrams.
In the particulate diagram on the left,
this is supposed to represent
the initial concentration
of our weak acid HA and there
are five particles of HA
and five particles of water.
Since weak acids only
partially ionize, let's say
that only one HA particle
reacts with one water molecule
to produce one hydronium
ion and one A-minus anion.
So if one HA particle reacts
with one H2O particle,
that gives us one hydronium,
H30-plus and one A-minus.
So out of the original five HA particles,
only one of them ionized,
leaving four HA particles
still in solution at
equilibrium, therefore HA
only partially ionized and is a weak acid,
the equilibrium constant
expression for a weak acid
looks the same as it
did for our strong acid,
because we use the same general equation.
However, since a weak acid
only partially ionizes
at equilibrium, there's
gonna be a small amount
of products and a large
amount of reactants.
Therefore, the Ka value for a weak acid
will be less than one.
Let's look at some Ka values
for some weak acids at 25 degrees Celsius.
Hydrofluoric acid has a Ka value
of 6.3 times 10 to the negative fourth,
and acetic acid has a Ka value
of 1.8 times 10 to the negative fifth.
Since both of these have
Ka values less than one,
they're both considered to be weak acids.
However, the higher the Ka
value, the stronger the acid.
So out of these two weak
acids, since hydrofluoric acid
has the higher Ka value, hydrofluoric acid
is the stronger acid of the two.
Now let's do a calculation
using a weak acid.
Let's say we have a 0.10 molar
solution of benzoic acid,
which is a weak acid, and
the pH of the solution
is 2.60 at 25 degrees Celsius.
Our goal is to calculate the Ka value
for benzoic acid at 25 degrees Celsius.
Since we're given the pH in the problem,
we can go ahead and plug the
pH of 2.60 into this equation.
So 2.60 is equal to the negative
log of the concentration
of hydronium ions, and to
solve for the concentration
of hydronium ions, first
moved the negative sign
to the left, which gives us negative 2.60,
is equal to log of the
concentration of hydronium ions.
And to get rid of the log,
we take 10 to both sides.
This gives us the
concentration of hydronium ions
is equal to 2.5 times 10 to
the negative third molar.
It's also important to recognize this is
the equilibrium concentration
of hydronium ions.
The next step is to write out the equation
showing benzoic acid reacting with water.
So here's the chemical
formula for benzoic acid
reacting with water to
form the hydronium ion
and the conjugate base to benzoic acid,
which is the benzoate anion.
To help us find the Ka
value for benzoic acid,
we're gonna use an ICE table,
where I stands for the
initial concentration,
C is the change in concentration,
and E is the equilibrium concentration.
In our problem, we were told
the initial concentration
of benzoic acid was 0.10
molar, and if we assume
that benzoic acid hasn't reacted yet,
the initial concentration of
hydronium ion would be zero,
and the initial concentration of benzoate
would also be zero.
We just calculated the
equilibrium concentration
of hydronium ions, which we found to be
2.5 times 10 to the negative third molar.
So we're going to go
ahead and put that under
our hydronium ion in for the
equilibrium concentration.
So if the initial concentration
of hydronium ion was zero
and the equilibrium concentration
is 2.5 times 10 to the
negative third, there was
an increase in 2.5 times
10 to the negative third,
so we're going to write
that under hydronium
for the change in the concentration.
And looking at the mole
ratio of hydronium ion
to benzoate, it's a one-to-one mole ratio.
So if hydronium ion increased
by 2.5 times 10 to the negative third,
so did the benzoate anions,
I can go ahead and write here
plus 2.5 times 10 to the negative third,
which means the equilibrium concentration
of benzoate anion would also be
2.5 times 10 to the negative third.
Since we saw an increase
in the concentration
of hydronium ion and
benzoate, that increase
in the concentration of the products
came from the ionization
of our weak acids.
In the balanced equation, there's a one
in front of benzoic acid, so if we write
plus 2.5 times 10 to the
negative third for hydronium,
and it's a one-to-one
mole ratio from hydronium
to benzoic acid, we would have to write
minus 2.5 times 10 to the negative third,
since we lost some of the
benzoic acid when it ionized,
therefore the equilibrium
concentration of benzoic acid
would be 0.10 minus 2.5 times
10 to the negative third.
Since our goal is to
calculate the Ka value
for benzoic acid, the
next step is to write out
the equilibrium constant expression,
which we get from the balanced equation.
It would be the concentration
of hydronium ions
times the concentration of benzoate anions
divided by the concentration
of benzoic acid.
Since these are
equilibrium concentrations,
we can get the equilibrium concentrations
from the ICE table and plug them in
to our equilibrium constant expression.
So we can plug in the
equilibrium concentration
for hydronium ions, we can plug in
the equilibrium concentration
for benzoate anions,
and we can plug in the
equilibrium concentration
for benzoic acid.
Here we have the
equilibrium concentrations
plugged in to the equilibrium
constant expression,
and when we solve for Ka, we find that Ka
for benzoic acid at 25 degrees Celsius
is equal to 6.4 times 10
to the negative fifth.
Notice that Ka is less than one
because benzoic acid is a weak acid.
Finally, let's talk about the
idea of percent ionization.
And to help us think
about percent ionization.
Let's go back to our
example with a strong acid.
We started off with five HA particles
and all five of those HA particles ionized
to produce five hydronium ions in solution
and five A-minus anions in solution.
Therefore 100% of our acid ionized.
So we can write 100% ionization
for this hypothetical strong acid HA.
Now let's go back to our weak acid.
For our weak acid, we started
off with five HA particles,
but only one of them ionized to produce
one H3O-plus and one A-minus.
So four remain unionized at equilibrium,
therefore one out of five
ionized, so the percent ionization
for this hypothetical
weak acid would be 20%.
Notice that the one
particle of HA that ionized
made one hydronium ion, so we can also use
the concentration of
hydronium ion at equilibrium
to calculate percent ionization.
So the equation for percent Ionization
is equal to the equilibrium concentration
of hydronium ions divided
by the initial concentration
of the acid HA times 100%.
So looking at our ICE table
for our benzoic acid problem,
the equilibrium concentration
of hydronium ions
was 2.5 times 10 to the
negative third molar,
and the initial concentration
of our acid was 0.10 molar,
so we can plug those into our equation.
So we plug in our concentrations
and molar cancels,
and we find for the final
answer, the percent ionization
of benzoic acid is equal to 2.5%.